now this the baboon here who's supposed
to be basically just a fool when the
story was first written he turned into
what's essentially a shaman across time
and so he represents the self from the
Union perspective now the self is
everything you could be across time so
you imagine that there's you and there's
the potential inside you whatever that
is you know and potential is an
interesting idea because it represents
something that isn't yet real yet we act
like it's real because people will say
to you you should live up to your
potential and that potential is partly
what you could be if you interacted with
the world in a manner that would gain
you the most information right because
you build yourself out of the
information in the piagetian sense but
it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment new
jeans turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized unless you move
yourself around in the world in two
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits so
it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
central and that would be say like the
rock in the Pride Rock and the Lion King
because you take yourself out of your
dopey little village and that's just a
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you like partly
because you're becoming informed which
means in formation it means you're
becoming more organized at every level
of analysis but there's also more of you
too and so that's a very classic idea
and then in in cathedrals in Europe
especially at Chartres there's a big
maze on the floor a circular maze which
is a symbolic representation of the
pilgrimage for people who couldn't do it
and so it's a huge circle divided into
quadrants which is a union Mandela and
you enter the maze at one point
then you have to walk through the entire
maze north east west and south before
you get to the center and the center is
symbolized by a flower that's carved in
stone it looks like this it's big this
maze a it's it's large so that you can
walk it and that's a symbolic pilgrimage
it takes you to the center that's the
center of the cross because it's in a
Cathedral and that's the point of
acceptance of voluntary suffering that's
what that means and so you walk through
you call that a circumambulation you go
to all the quarters of the world to find
yourself and so well the self is the
baboon in this particular in this piece
of mandrill actually in this particular
representation and he lives in the tree
he lives in the tree of life it's a bale
bob tree in this particular so he's the
spirit that inhabits the Tree of Life
and he's the eternal wise man that's a
way of thinking so is the king but that
he's he's sort of a superordinate king
or an outside king in some sense he's
the repository of ancient wisdom and the
king is the manner in which that wisdom
is currently being acted out in the
world and so they're friends and that
means that the king is a good king
because if they if the king was a bad
king he would be alienated from himself
and that would make him shallow and
one-dimensional and that would make him
a bad ruler no Union with the traditions
of the past to be a good ruler you have
to rescue your father from the
underworld and integrate that and of
course that's a main theme in this
entire movie